foreign
David is on the line David how can we
help
hey Karen hey Jade how you doing what's
going on David
uh just a quick question or kind of a
it's kind of based on careers like you
were talking about uh so I uh
recently I got a great opportunity uh at
another company back in April I was I
was actually really happy where I was
but they weren't quite um
paying me with paying me what I what I
knew I would I could make with my uh my
education that I have and the experience
I have because I have a Six Sigma Black
Belt and um so this other company gave
me a call offered me 27 000 more years
to come uh join join their uh join their
team so so of course I I did give my
employer at the time you know the
opportunity to counter uh
make a calendar offer uh they couldn't
match uh so I ended up joining the new
team I think it was going really good
um but then we had some management
changes
um so long story short now so now I'm
kind of working as a say like a
warehouse analyst what I do is I just
kind of uh
track orders and why we're not getting
things to customers on time
um and the the thing is like now I
really don't have any purpose there is I
just kind of find out what's going on
every day and you know let them know
what's what the problem is and and I I
don't have a problem working for for
bosses that are younger than me
um except the the one I do work for now
is uh he's nine years younger and he is
a lot of experience that a lot of
development left in them and HR was
actually hoping that I could help
develop him
um and uh
so David I feel like I feel like you're
kind of dancing around the issue yeah
and I think you're trying to be really
nice
oh yeah and I hear two issues but I
really want you to tell me what is it
that you want help with today
I just don't know what I what I what I
need to do with my career anymore it's
just yeah I don't see any purpose yeah
you took a page you took a higher
paycheck and you got no purpose good
news I wrote a book called from paycheck
to purpose and I'll give you that
um I promise I didn't put him up to that
folks that's not a paid plug uh but the
issue is is now we've got to figure out
what we want to do and then what you're
bringing up is adding insult to injury
and the injury is
there's no meaning in your work you got
no juice right is the way I like to say
it so now you're going on top of that
they want you to Mentor a kid and you
feel like why am I doing that I don't
even like what I'm doing and then I
gotta help a guy who's younger and more
inexperienced than I am and so it's just
creating this frustration am I right
yeah
it's and the other thing is like he
doesn't really want to take advice from
me yeah but here's the deal that's a
non-factor you don't want to be there
correct yeah you shouldn't be training
your boss yeah this is that makes zero
sense so we need to come up with an
extra strategy that's really why you
called right hey Ken help me get out of
there but help me figure out where to
get to am I right
yeah I would say so yes you would say so
do you have a couple of ideas of what
you would like to do I mean you were
doing something before City's
Improvement I mean I love I love
teaching people how to make their job
easier okay but you're not getting to do
that in this current role and
what's up you're not getting to do that
in this current role correct no not
right were you doing that in your
previous role
yes yeah
so there's a term for folks like you or
people that could beat you which is
boomerang employees where they go back
to their previous employer do you think
that's possible
uh their Market their their RVs so
they're actually at a dollar right now
with the economy and uh okay so that's
not what I'm asking you don't want to go
back there it's not is it possible so
you don't want to go back there so the
good news is we're going to go back to
your previous job and we're going to say
okay this is what I love to do I'm
essentially leading but the way that I
lead is that I want to be instructing
coaching that's what I heard and what
you said is that a true classification
for what I think you said
yes all right so where can I do that
and it's less about the industry it
doesn't sound like to me there's a
certain industry or a product or service
that you're fired up about it sounds
like to me you want to be in a
leadership position and and the work you
want to be spending most of your time on
is work where you are guiding
instructing mentoring coaching so that's
the job description
and it may not say it that way
but you got to dig into it in the
interview process going okay this is my
style of leadership and I want to come
in and this is how I like the lead and
and so for you it's it's it's a it's an
open field out there you're not sitting
around scratching your head on this do
you understand what I'm saying
yes how are you feeling right now what's
your confidence level
well when you put it out that way I
think uh you got a lot more confidence
there it is what did we do there we got
clear
so David you got to stay in a place of
clarity all right that was a setup
question uh I was prepared to deal with
it Jade if he said he was not confident
but I thought he would be more confident
than he is and the reason David that
you're confident and I'm I'm reviewing
this because I want you to get off this
phone call and here's what's going to
happen when you get off this phone call
Jade I can tell you that fear and doubt
will present themselves in the days
ahead fear is I'm I am worried that
something bad is going to happen doubt
is I don't believe that Something Good
Can Happen David hear me my friend when
fear and doubt pop up on your shoulder
you've got to go back to this initial
conversation right here and you've got
to say here's what I know
I am good at leading coaching
instructing and guiding people is that a
true or false statement
it's true it's true now we're going to
move to I love guiding and instructing
and leading people is that true or false
that is true and then we're going to say
I am motivated
to help people win
professionally and personally is that a
true or false statement
absolutely all right so what we did Dave
we just walked through Talent love it
what he does best passion what he loves
to do and then Mission what motivates
him so David we Retreat back to Clarity
when we are confronted by fear and doubt
and when that happens now you go okay I
know why I'm leaving
I know why I'm going over here and then
that will give you the confidence to
press forward and Jade here's the best
part there's three C's
Clarity leads to confidence and
confidence leads to courage you're
preaching Ken oh